[Music]
today's question comes from ashley in
ohio ashley writes my husband and i
fight all the time and need counseling
in our finances we're pretty equal with
spending but i get blamed for being a
spender he makes 200k a year and we are
out of debt
except for our house we have about nine
years left on our mortgage and i'm sick
of pinching pennies i compared myself
with our friends all the time we make
more money than so many people and yet
we have old cars
i'm over it and i'm to the point where i
could go back in debt to live and say
yes to the kids more
how can i get out of this mindset
i need some more information here for
this one dave but
you've dealt with this a long time i
i have a hard time with
the limited data set i have here um
i have a hard time with the attitude i
guess i struggle with that hers yes
and it may be again some more data would
let me know if
a husband is
super controlling and won't let anybody
spend anything or he only gets to spend
things
um
but when it comes to i compare myself
with my friends i'm ready to get back
into debt so we can go have some fun
i have a hard time with that one i also
have a hard time making 200 000
and you all haven't created space for
y'all to enjoy your life
right yeah
um
i i may be
reading too much into this but i just
see two selfish immature people yeah
both of you want your little thing
and neither one of you are willing to
put the other one first number one and
worse than that neither one of you are
willing to put the good of the overall
household ahead of your own little crap
you're acting actually you're sound like
a spoiled princess it sounds like a
child or
you are
a
a wife who has absolutely no vote
because your husband's an overbearing
ogre
uh nerd with his spreadsheet but he gets
to do whatever he wants
both of these are selfish immature
reactions
what both of you should do
is look to say okay what is the best
plan
for the good of our overall household
and what is that you know what is the
best plan we have taught that the best
plan to do is called the baby steps and
depending on where you are in the baby
steps it sounds like you're in four or
five and six then you don't have to
pinch pennies if you're out of debt
everything but the house
and you have an emergency fund in place
but you two have not done a budget that
you both agreed to that was aimed at a
bigger goal than either one of you
the only thing you do the reason you
have fights is when you sit down you
want to get what he you want he wants to
get what he wants instead of going okay
what's the big goal you're not dreaming
bigger than either one of you your dream
is
i want something i want equal all right
my vote needs to get
we need a big goal that's bigger than
either one of you
a bigger vision a better clearer vision
that you both can buy into and you're
both willing to sacrifice equally to hit
that goal
and consistently to hit that goal
but this sounds like two kids fighting
over
who you he's got my toy he got my joint
i want my grandkids when i'm keeping